hi everyone I'm Lizzy Wade welcome to
science magazines chat on the science of
Superman and other superheroes I'm with
with me today are Jim Kathy Leo's pause
there and Sean Carroll and you're
waiting your question on the website you
can leave them in the comments below at
any time during the chat so thanks very
much for joining to meet no thanks so
much for joining me today everyone um
I'm really looking forward to this so
let's start since we started with the
Man of Steel little theaters right now
let's start with the science of Superman
so I know Paul you recently wrote about
the sides of his super strength for
scientific american and i was wondering
if you could tell us a little more about
that yeah thanks Lizzie and thanks for
inviting me to be on the show it's a
pleasure to talk with chairman and sean
today and hear questions i was really
interested all the time and trying to
think about you know what reality what
kind of real be all biology is behind
super powers or could be so i looked at
super strength and thought well what do
we know about strength regulation in
people on earth now us humans and one of
the really interesting things that's
emerged over the last number of years is
that our biology has multiple
redundancies of things that help make us
stronger but also things that help keep
us from getting too strong and one of
these things is a protein called
myostatin and another one's called
active in a and they normally act to
keep people from getting too strong for
muscles getting too large and from the
muscle fibers getting to be too numerous
and what was noticed quite a long time
ago originally in people who had animal
husbandry raising the cattle for four
feet and so on was that sometimes these
cows would be humongous they'd have huge
muscles they called them double muscled
and it turned out they had a mile Staten
gene deletion so they didn't have this
regulatory protein present and so I
started thinking about well you know
what maybe there was a way that Superman
had some similar biology to what we have
us humans you know it seems to local
not like us even though he's from way
across to you and what how would that
work what can actually happen in a
person's body to give them extra
strength and so I talked about how you
could have a MOSFET and gene deletion
would be one way or experimentally you
could inject something that actually
knocks out the mile statins function
normally there's another molecule called
Paula statin which actually works to
turn off mile statin and has been used
in animal research and monkeys most
recently to make their strength a lot
more than they normally have so I kind
of postulated that yeah you could have
some super strength it's not as super as
it ought to be it's only like a
twenty-five to thirty percent
strengthing creates that you wear the
knockout myostatin you could get a lot
stronger right away just using your own
biology whoa um and so one of the things
with Superman I know it's a red Sun
yellow sign the debate difference um and
I was wondering Jim if you could talk a
little bit about about those
possibilities since he wrote this book
physics of superheroes right um so
superman first appeared in comic books
in june nineteen thirty-eight created by
these two teenagers Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster from Cleveland Ohio outside of
Cleveland and they were fans of science
fiction pulp magazines and at the time
those were what we might call now hard
science fiction in that they would try
to take um only one impossible thing and
see what the ramifications were a very
popular series um in these magazines was
the John Carter of Mars series by Edgar
Rice Burroughs where an Earthman goes to
Mars and because Mars has a weaker
gravity than Earth is able to leap great
distances and fight you know any
warriors at the same time is enhanced
strength and enhanced abilities so they
took that and they turned it around and
they had the alien come to earth and so
Earth has a week of gravity than Krypton
so Superman is able to lift cars
overhead leap an eighth of a mile
nothing less than a bursting shell could
penetrate his skin um and that was the
source of his strength originally he
first started flying in the fly
sure cartoons these were cartoons that
were made for movie theaters and the
animators thought that it was a time
consuming and kind of boring because
only showing him crouching down and
jumping so they wanted him to just fly
eventually the flight translated it over
to the comics and then he started to get
powers and abilities that could not be
accounted for by just a larger gravity
and so eventually they did what's called
a retroactive continuity they a retcon
they changed his origin the source of
his powers so that our son Saul has
eigen is a Yellow Sun appears yellow to
us Krypton Sun Rao um I know it's sad
that I know this but that is a red Sun
and apparently that shift in peak
wavelength of 80 nanometers it is
sufficient to enable someone to change
the course of mighty river's so uh
basically then super may have started to
become more of a fantasy character than
a science fiction character uh because
his power it then they just said well
his Kryptonian physiology arm when it
absorbs the scarred sun's radiation
endow is him with all of these powers
and abilities beyond what Paul said he's
got like extra tough actin tinactin
itself so that the sunlight is just
basically is an excuse to UM oh and it
was also introduced um I'm going on on a
nerdy tangent here to explain why the
Kryptonians didn't get off the planet
it's like our planet is going to explode
let's put a baby in a rocket ship
incision its outer space that's our plan
but why didn't the rest of them if they
have Superman's powers leave and the
explanation is that Superman would not
have powers if he was on Krypton none of
the proponents did because Krypton had a
red Sun great so let's think a little
bit more about this dividing line or
blurry
a flying between science fiction and
fantasy and i was wondering sean if you
had any thoughts on whether you think
superman is more science fiction a more
aware of a science fiction character or
more of a fantasy character it's been
just argued yeah I mean I think Jim is
absolutely right like by now by these
days Superman is certainly a fantasy
character as most comic book characters
are I mean green lantern is even worse
right but Batman maybe is more science
fictiony maybe the least make an attempt
but you know that's okay and I think
that it's a the there's there's what
this comic book writers try to do is to
create some logic right to create some
rules but not the rules of our universe
but you'd like to create the rules and
then you have some idea what the
character can do and cannot do without
physics as i like to say there is no
drama because without laws of nature
even if it's not our nature there's
nothing you can't do and there's nothing
interesting is so interesting conflict
if you can defeat anybody at any time
just by you know flicking your eyeballs
so you need these limitations and the
rules of the fictional world provide
those limitations typically it's more
fun to have the fictional world have
rules that are different than our world
so you're allowed to fly and you're
forced to wear you know the suit and
everything but the problem comes in as
Jim also alluded to when the rules tend
to change depending on who is writing
the comic book that actively Superman in
particular became a real problem that
they would just start adding powers
whenever they felt that it was necessary
and that actually makes the comic less
interesting so you need to wreck on
everything and remove Superman's powers
you can always you could plot Superman's
powers versus time they go up they go
down again and we go up again they go
down they go up and they go down it's a
universal curve for superpowers over
time fascinating and what about when you
start combining when comic book
characters into one world like what
happens when you take all these
characters that exist separately and
then put them together into one well I
think that's an accrued crucially
important issue because
was the feeling to the reader or the
viewer is very different for example in
a comic book than in a movie in the
comic books you have you know Spider Man
and Doctor Strange are always howling
around and Superman and Batman get into
fights and Batman wins and that makes no
sense if you know what what they can
both do with the Avengers movie Marvel
had in mind for years ahead of time that
they were going to want to have Tony
Stark and the Mighty Thor standing next
to each other teaming up and one of them
is a Norse God and the other guy is a
guy in an iron suit and how is this
going to fit together so they wanted to
put everything into a common context
they wouldn't have a universe that made
sense which is why in for the movie they
make very explicit that the Asgardians
are an advanced alien race with super
technology they're not truly Norse gods
or rather they were the North Scott they
are these aliens that the Norse people
took his gods nor I can call them gods
yes that is great I mean if you went
back in time a thousand years ago and
you had a functioning iPad somehow even
without you know connections to Wi-Fi uh
you know they would hell you with some
sort of wizard right before they burned
us take that today it still happens so
I'm you know I'm used to that happening
so that's funny you know Lizzie I really
like the the take that but Marvel's done
with Thor with giving that advanced
technology piece and I like how it rips
on arthur c clarke comment about
advanced technology from from a certain
civilization if it's sufficiently
advanced would look like magic to to
another civilization so i think they did
a really nice kind of job of skating
around the issue of sci-fi and fantasy
with that character the way it's
portrayed in the movies great uh so
let's go back to Superman for one second
um Henry had a question on our website
and to all the viewers out there please
continuous leave your comments
throughout the chat um how can you
possibly account for Superman's vision
powers the heat the laser x-ray
etc designed to be one of the most
precious organs in the university said
and not to mention like the rest of his
body they're invulnerable so he really
doesn't need glasses so what what is he
doing wearing them so anyone have
anything to say about super inside um
I'll say something just very general
rather than specific which is that if
you start by treating the comic books as
experimental data and trying to come up
with a theory that could explain it you
know that way lies madness it's it's
very very difficult to do that I think a
better way to spend one's time is you
know much like Paul did to take the
stories that are in the comic books and
to say you know what does that inspire
us to think about what are the
limitations that we have in our real
world you know x-ray eyes keep vision
things like that they they're not real
they're not going to exist it's not a
matter of you know tweaking the
mitochondria here and there but we have
lasers we have ways to keep things up
using electromagnetic radiation we have
x-ray telescopes we have ways to make
pictures of things using x-rays and so
forth x-ray machines so I think that's
actually the useful thing all good
science starts with you know
hypothesizing ideas either out of the
blue horse or inspired by some data and
that data can be from an experiment or
that data can be thought experiment data
such as we find in becoming books well i
would say that um regarding heat vision
there is a theory that's been posted on
the web by been tipping the unified
theory of of Superman's powers that
tries to account for the vast Penelope
of his abilities that boils it down to
Superman has this ability to control
inertia his own inertia the inertia of
other objects and so if you can increase
or decrease his own inertia or
especially if he can change his arm rest
frame at will he could move at super
speeds or very fast he could fly he
broke because if right now were
stationary relative to the surface of
the earth if we were set stationary
relative to the fixed stars we'd be
moving relatives in
surface a year and people would see that
as flying the heat vision if he could
change the inertia of things that he's
looking at if he could change the mess
all the atoms right now in our bodies
are vibrating because we're at 98.6
degrees Fahrenheit and we're a meeting
infrared radiation about as much as a
hundred watt light bulb you just can't
see it because we're too cool we're just
not vibrating and admitting in the
visible but if he could change say the
mass of these objects that are vibrating
if you change the mass of a spring but
keep the total energy the same its
vibration rates will will shift
dramatically and if the vibration
frequencies change dramatically you
might have a melting transition you
might have you be seeing that as a
heating up of something that you're
looking at so in that sense you could
say that connected to his ability to
lift a building and not have it crumble
under its own weight ought to have
bullets strike him and bounce off he
either is changing the inertia of the
bullets or he's changing his own inertia
ah heat vision is part of that as well